morning everyone good morning
Millennials welcome back to the morning
toast your daily live morning show that
you absolutely love and adore love and
adore love and adore we have a
jam-packed show for you today because it
dawned on us that we you have been
forgetting to do to your toasters for a
couple weeks because Jacob is no longer
with us and we're not intact anymore we
don't have we're not into Natori but we
will be because I heard that we're
getting an intern soon yeah who's
running in August
it's very snitchy know she's very
prestigious we actually poached her for
Morgan Stanley yeah they were very upset
at us they were but I think that they
understood that she definitely has toast
running through her veins yes and that
she needed to be here upon her return to
America Marga will be our intern
starting August 1st and like you think
like just she's our sister we're gonna
like let her get by like we are working
that [ __ ] to the BA contraire we are
guys if anything we'll feel better about
like bossing her yeah because she needs
a little passing around she's been
running wild in Israel and it's time for
a little structure for oh and just to be
clear she will not be paid no she well
but she'll be there she will not
oh she's sorry she won't but it's
psychological income like what's all the
words from being an intern on the toes
I'm sure that Instagram followers which
is all she really wants right it's
something that money can't buy and when
you are absent this August on your shows
she will be subbing in as co-hosts so
speaking of she little does she know
speaking of shows Thank You Jackie for
that setup at La I'm just gonna lob it
right in two things presale ends
officially today for Boston and tickets
go on sale to the public tomorrow
presale was very overwhelming because
people who are eligible for presale were
like sending the link to their friends
which I don't mind cuz like the more the
merrier
after it made people buy but it's not
fair for people who like actually
followed the rules but there are tickets
left I will not be adding a second show
so make sure to get them this is Boston
Boston which I'm just really grateful
because I didn't know I told you guys
100 times a cutpurse Steve just so over
theater isn't like it's just a big deal
so thank you for for coming out pulling
out all the stops
additionally I will be in Denver and st.
Louis next week seeing Louis I think
it's Thursday night it's sold out and
I'm not doing a second show sorry but
Denver is Saturday night and it's a
bigger theater and I have a whole
Orchestra per plant planned because like
I'm gonna be in a theater I have to sing
also it's in Colorado which I didn't
realize
we're Potter's are you gonna be sky-high
Colorado
if-if-if I'm feeling crazy I'm gonna
write before I leave stage because I'm
gonna like no I can't cuz like I don't
do drugs but like I'm gonna do something
with pot and it's gonna be crazy so you
can only do it after your show please
because my god of course can you imagine
me like freaking out on stage no I'm not
good with drugs like it's not my thing
but it's legal so it's technically not
it's just like drinking coffee like
doing smoking pot in Colorado is just
like dropping off your knees
so I know it's illegal do you know what
I mean but not when you're sky high in
Colorado when I finally get that line
and wonder if my lips are gonna be
pressed against the bottle well that's
for sure but that can happen anywhere
yeah so Denver oriental theater tickets
available car with no job com I really
want to see everyone so make sure that
you're coming in people are like waiting
to buy tickets and it's almost sold out
so like stop waiting yeah there's no
time like the present
I'm speaking of the present let's jump
into the past I stories say you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast good morning
everyone good morning it feels like 5:00
p.m. I've had such a busy morning I've
had a weirdly busy morning too and I
just have a very busy day so I have no
time to be tired you know me too I had
literally the worst migraine of all time
last night like cripplingly so Ben was
like out and about me I've just been
waiting to sleep with a headache waking
up with a headache how I meant to bring
you electronics well so I was like I was
I had a migraine for about six hours and
Ben we were supposed to go to a van but
I was like really not feeling good
so Ben went without me and then he like
turned it into a night the town last
night you know it was like a little
annoying and I was like mad and he was
with a girl and I was like excuse I mean
watching historian he was just like
going from one event to the next I was
like who is this man no I know like Ben
is like so Benesch so much energy like
actually I'm jealous of it like he works
full-time and like gets home and like
goes out and like plays basketball and I
came up with friends was like I work
half a day and I'm exhausted and I
realize I'm exhausted because I work
half a day but I was just I was jealous
whatever so I had a terrible like like
the worst migraine ever and I knew it
was because I really have not been I cut
down like what I'm eating probably by
50% and I didn't have any excedrin in my
house which sometimes works for me but
if it's a real migraine it doesn't
really work so I like laid around like a
stick flash for like hours until Ben
finally got home six hours later and
brought me a Pedialyte it's just
necessary and excedrin and I literally
felt better in
five minutes and I can't believe I let
myself fester for six hours because I'm
so [ __ ] lazy and I live right by
7-eleven and it was free slurpie day and
I didn't go like I should have just
gotten up and away mm-hmm so it works
really quickly other electrolytes don't
but I think it's cuz it has like sugar
and everything that you need but you
gotta get that pedialite you have to
Pedialyte in your house I have two
bottles in my house for emergencies now
I have two
I need more tomorrow when you're
hungover speaking of tomorrow we thought
about it a lot and we're first of all I
just want to say I think this has been
like the best week of the toast yet I
think so too between the well-rounded
stories the gas the guests and like
we've just been being really funny yeah
and I'm getting a lot of sleep that's
what it is and I don't want the week to
be over today I know but my birthday
party's tonight and it's gonna be so
late because it's sponsored by cos
amigos so like no one essent worried
about paying for drink so you can really
just drink with a free conscious you
know so we have decided to not not do a
show tomorrow cuz we want to do it but
10:30 like it'll hinder my good time if
I know I have to wake up sort of early
so we're gonna push back the time maybe
to like 12:30 1:00 o'clock we'll confirm
later on Instagram so make sure you file
at the morning toast on Instagram for
any and all scheduling updates so we
will be going live from here tomorrow
just later in the afternoon and I think
that might work better for your Friday
schedules too you can get all your work
done in the morning I actually chose to
go home exactly not but watch the shows
me Talia the watercooler
that didn't go home it's a dream but
yeah I feel I feel really strong about
this week of shows and I always say to
people like if you're trying to I always
meet girls who like arc I'm trying to
convince like one of their co-workers
one of their friends to like join our
cult and they're like they don't know
how to show them like I would show them
episodes from this week exactly also
speaking of great episodes premium
content we are filming our next patreon
episode today because we had such
success with our award for original film
with our first original film we're doing
another original film and it's gonna be
all about the behind the scenes of
Claudia's birthday party us getting
ready and then on-site at the birthday
talking to all of us on the ground
prestigious guests and I'm really
excited to film it I'm really well I
only did one so far but I'm really
enjoying vlogging today and the life
Dana live so hopefully this is just as
enjoyable so that we can continue making
videos one more announcement since we're
bothering you it's imperative that all
of you like us on facebook follow us on
Instagram and YouTube the YouTube is
youtube.com forward slash the morning
toast we go live there too and there's
premiere
comment I would say it's a little bit
even more lit than Facebook sorry
make chains on the day yes make sure you
like us on Facebook the morning toast
there to Instagram the morning toast and
now we're on Twitter the morning toast
just make sure you're you're getting
content from all facades you know yes so
without further ado it is time to hit
you with the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast the
first story is the majority Lee Jenner
by an unexpected assailant and it's not
even shot day better in LA because
that's an insult today it's totally and
honestly today is not today no no no no
nice girl she's so nice she's so
prestigious I saw her last night on my
television I know I saw your Instagram
story that was so funny and I just hope
that like she knows who we are and like
does not take offense because we would
call we would say the word shade Shaddai
like we say family family yeah and then
like she happens to be named Sharda
better in LA and she's just the most
prestigious local news anchor in our
city and she used to have the most
prestigious commercials all over the
Diana shidae hi remember those right so
it was just inevitable and when we say
shy they been her and we only mean it in
a positive way exactly and we would love
to have her on the show totally okay so
Kylie Jenner was attacked in her sleep
last night
by the one the only dictionary.com she
knows hit over the head with a
dictionary
it's so weird and it's so rude and it's
so shady and I'm not here for it and
there whoever wrote this tweet is
extremely brave because they have a
death threat okay ready
so whoever runs the dictionary.com
Twitter quote tweeted the Forbes article
which was how Kylie Jenner leveraged her
massive social media following to build
a 900 million dollar cosmetics brand
they they quote we did it and reply to
it self-made means having succeeded in
life unaided used in a sentence Forbes
says that Kylie Jenner is a self-made
woman
thus these trolls are implying that
Kylie Jenner is not a self-made woman
and I put um Kylie Jenner's a Forbes
article on my Instagram story last night
I was just like I'm so proud of her I'm
like you would not believe the flack
people are so upset that they use the
term self-made because she comes from a
wealthy family a famous family Kris
Jenner probably helps her orchestrate it
but what self-made means is fine what
they meant by that was financially so
she one hundred percent of the business
she never had an investor she never had
a partner it's
all her no it is people jealous a
jealous people are so jealous it's crazy
it's not a good look you guys
also you want to come at her for sang
self made like Chloe's not on the cover
of Forbes Britney's not on the cover of
Forbes Kendall's not even on the Kim has
been kiddin has been but like she yes
she was born with a silver spoon in her
mouth but she took that silver spoon and
she ate your ass Wow very nice thank you
no I'm just like I'm so not here for the
coming of Kylie and the Kardashians in
general but like okay say what you want
about about her Kylie like leveraging
her family's connections and her
popularity to make the social media
following but not one person can deny
that from a financial standpoint Kylie
is a self-made billionaire yeah like how
can you argue with that it's facts it's
its financial facts its fiscal facts I
feel so bad for the fiscal family it's
like she was born rich and she didn't
just stay rich like she is building
wealth my friends and you know what that
takes Talent know right like Courtney
was born rich and is still like kind of
rich she doesn't really do much
financially on her own she just like
rakes in the e money and the Instagram
money and lives a very good life kylie
is like a hardcore businesswoman just
saying just saying like they're not
writing this about good American right
right exactly
I would have but even good American even
if it were a billion dollar company that
would be Khloe has an investor she is
she's partnered with a woman who like
really is like the backing of it I don't
know if financially but definitely firm
like a business yeah wait so they
couldn't say that she is a self-made
billionaire even if it was a billion
dollar company because she doesn't own
the whole thing right there's a couple
people involved turning Fame and
Instagram followers into cold hard cash
is a lot harder than you think like oh
we're trying no and all of these digital
people who yeah they can sell tea on
Instagram and make money like trying to
move product even if you have a lot of
influence is not a given no no people
think that and that's like when you work
with brands that's like the most
frustrating part they think oh you have
2.8 million followers we'll put this
t-shirt and you'll make 2.0 and we'll
sell 2.8 million t-shirts and that's
just so not how it works it's a one
thing to have a following but another
thing to have influence and to be able
to make your followers transactional and
make them like buy stuff is so
impressive so like I don't think when
when Kim's putting up her lollipops that
she's generating sales you know
that Kim and Kylie when they post up
like they generate a lot of sales and
that's impressive because even someone
with the same amount of followers as
them might not be able to do that right
exactly so people like are so quick to
jump on the Kardashians especially Kylie
and like I'm not here for it and that
will use this very small platform to
discredit those arguments someone
commented the funniest thing yesterday
because we turn everything and the
Kardashians which I think was people
really enjoy because we're having new
arguments about also it's a talent and
someone we started talking about peanuts
someone was like I heard Kim's allergic
to peanut also someone commented
something so interesting about the
chemicals that the peanut allergy is
that like years ago there were less
people with allergies and now there are
more because peanuts aren't as prevalent
so people aren't being exposed to them
so by the time they are exposed to them
they have an allergy towards that Oh in
in our banning of peanut butter peanuts
we are making the allergy more
prevalence yes and then someone said it
she's a nurse she was like you should be
exposed to peanuts
at 6 months but if you do have an
allergy which a lot of people looking at
before deadly and like that's really bad
but if you aren't gonna if you wouldn't
have developed an allergy you should be
exposed to it as soon as possible that
is so interesting very interesting I
don't know I just now I'm even more
motivated to like constantly eat peanut
butter just to make sure I don't develop
and like what about an allergy what
about Jeff
by the by Skippy is very in tune with
what's necessary their commercials
ending with smoother than a fresh dry
skippy what is genius
it's genius I love when brands partner
with like songs that like mention them
like my perfect example is to actually
blue Tacoma by Russell Dickerson should
be bad no I know but that's why this is
my platform because Russell Dickerson
song blue to come but which is about a
blue do you want to taste tonight just
for those few people haven't heard it
wins rolling on a new toy yo and I
should I want to start at the core sorry
you need a snack if heaven it is
anywhere it's in a blue to coma
California white magnolias in your hair
raise a gold shining
Anya oh if Heaven is anywhere it's never
running out of Golden Road always have
in your hand to hold and a blue Tacoma
California oh if Heaven is anywhere it's
right here so they never use that in
like a blue Tacoma Toyota commercial
which is so frustrating and I don't
think they ever like gifted him at
Tacoma which was just not in tune with
what's necessary not furthermore the
fact that coca-cola which they're always
in tune with what's necessary their
commercials have the best music that
Avicii song that they wrote like so good
they're always in tune are not in tune
because they have done nothing with that
marinara song sugar sugar sugar you made
the world taste better better good on
anything want you on everything just a
little bit is all it takes like a
coca-cola on Christmas Day never used in
a commercial a holiday coca-cola
commercial nothing and I asked her I was
like Maron
literally the first thing I met her when
I ever asked her was like for first of
all I was like hi can I kiss him and
then I was like why didn't they use
sugar in a coca-cola commercial and she
was approached but they had some
creative differences and so we let
bygones be bygones
ah agreed but why were we talking about
this I don't know tracer steps
okay sorry on songs transactional grants
cooler then ACOTA butter peanut butter
yeah
yes I actually rewatched some of our
episode with Raven yesterday and I was
listening to myself and even I couldn't
understand myself yeah I realized I
really need to slow down and enunciate
and it's gonna be a challenge but I'm
working on it let's try from here on out
for this episode she talks flower it's
not even the speed I've just started to
slur I am there so rated I'm having such
a hard time talking lightly there are so
many things that we need to talk about
in one episode
so the show would really be to ours if
you just talked at this pace I also need
like a notebook because when you're
talking I have thoughts but I'm trying
not to interrupt you but I don't want to
forget me too when you were just singing
all of those songs I had so many
thoughts and I forgot them all that's
why when we stopped singing I had
nothing to say you know what I'm gonna
get us like TV dinner tables that you
put over your legs with some notes like
pink ones I like that because then I
don't have to worry about my thighs yeah
yeah we need desks I think I think so
too
but still the Thrones but also desks
okay like school like school
remember those desks Atlit lift it up
that we're connected like that was
always my dream to sit at a desk that
wasn't table and chair that was like you
slide in yeah but you saw in the movies
and we never had them we didn't yes we
did we did but they were not the same
they don't go up it was just a table
there yeah I just like like hated school
when it was going on and I still do like
those people my age like are going back
to school like I can't even begin to
relate to them on any sort of level our
high school started at 7:45 till 1:00
till 5:00 we could barely get here at 10
o'clock we can't keep you past 4:00 you
can barely go live everyday at 10:30 and
we used to have to be at high school at
7:45 no I know and it's like when I
think back I'm like all that energy I
used to have I'm like where did it go I
know but I remember even waking up as a
high schooler was so hard we wake up at
like 7 o'clock that's so early however
that is the time we'll be waking up for
camp toast because we need to make the
most out of our days but also like even
in college we're like you had a much
more relaxed schedule sometimes you
start a class at like noon I was still
it wasn't even about the waking up it's
just like I can't even with school I
can't with reading I can't with writing
I can't with like traditional like
scholar like [ __ ] like I am just a
creative person and I have street smarts
and I just can't even with like the
rigidness that is schooling I modern
schooling I can't and I I don't know the
amount that you would have to pay me to
go back to school like to go get my
masters or something and like the thing
of bread alone me paying you right right
and like all these people that like go
to grad school like I can't understand
it like I wake up every day no matter
how treacherous my day is like I'm so
grateful I'm not in school
I think all the time about how like
sometimes I
Marisa I worry I have nightmares said I
have a paper due and I haven't done it
and I wake up and I'm just so grateful
and the thing about the schooling system
is like I was never really like a smart
kid like with grades wise and you feel
like a failure like you're not gonna do
anything but like I feel like I'm an
accomplished ish person and I was like
on the lower spectrum of like the smarts
and they like I feel like when you're
putting that sort of like environment
where grades and like numbers define you
not to be lame but like it makes you
feel like [ __ ] about yourself I loved
going to my high school reunion because
I absolutely love to see the kids who
were so smart and like went to great
high colleges and like asking them what
they're doing and they do the same [ __ ]
as me I work in media some girls like oh
I work I just left a startup and I'm
working for my brother like all these
kids who were like idols in high school
who were geniuses are like they're just
like us and they were so annoying about
it too there was a hierarchy based off
of like intellect which I just think is
so [ __ ] up because you can't like I'm
sorry knowing like algebra does not make
you a better person
no but there's one thing of math that I
use in everyday life and you know what
it is let me think
proportions like percentage over x over
100 yeah anytime you need a percentage I
always do x over 100 and I like I do it
for everything even I was watching Mad
Men and it was like trying to figure out
how much Don made when they sold the
company right and it's always x over 100
equals 12 percent of Don Sterling Cooper
over at X Oh No whatever and then I
would figure out how much he made and
then I try and figure out how much that
would be today but that's percentages
and we learned it in the third grade
right but that old after that useless
division helps you when you're splitting
the check that's also third grade you
say all the math that I really like rely
on that green theorem never needed it
and I just think you at an early stage
you should make a decision if you want
to be an engineer or something where you
need math and you should go down that
track no I think it's it's definitely
good but it's when I have kids and I
have to help them with their homework
like once so vasa it's great I don't I
don't know what I'm I have to do we're
gonna have to go to brain camp so
embarrassing so embarrassing also
speaking of Mad Men I have to say and I
know you don't watch but I finished Blue
Bloods
I saw your story and I was just trying
to spoil just in case I ever watch it I
have to I'm sorry
okay I'll never watch it you won't watch
it it's not your show and it's eight
seasons and it's the last episode of the
eighth one and I didn't realize I was on
the final episode because I've been just
like so
caught up in it and I'm so invested in
this couple it's the youngest son he's
just a regular beat cop and his partner
is Eddie and they're like totally in
love and like for eight years they like
they've kissed like once they just they
did you can't be together because it's
like partners are not allowed and it's
just in the last episode Jamie got shot
and like she did I missed but she like
ran to his defense and killed the guy
that that shot Jamie and she turned
around and he was alive and they just
looked at each other and they were like
she like really thought she lost him you
know like not only like her partner in
crime like the love of her life and she
just looked at him and she was like they
just they knew it you know and what I
loved people were angry didn't show them
kiss and like love cuz it's a very
family show people were mad like didn't
get to see them [ __ ] like relax what
they had the way they did it was amazing
first of all this is the best part just
follow me for two seconds the whole
episode they were talking about what
they would do if they had five million
dollars like how they would distribute
it and they were going back and forth
about like what charities even gift you
like we do that so he was like I do some
to my cousin and when they're they're
reunited she thought he died and they
both realized like what have they been
doing like life's too short they hug and
he whispers in her ear he's like I spend
the five million on you it was so cute
and then I'm like they just hugged and
I'm like what happened are they gonna
get together so at the end of every
episode the Reagan's have dinner it's
like this beautiful dinner where they
the food looks so good and they're
always eating in real shows and then
it's annoying cuz they never eaten real
TV and they just have like discussions
about like ethical issues that are going
on it's always like a good conversation
and Jamie was late and Jamie's never
late they're like why Jamie right where
is he
he finally shows up and he gets an extra
chair and they're like who's extra chair
for and they bring an Eddie and then
everyone's like oh hey Eddie and he's
like don't call her Eddie the future
mrs. Jamie Reagan they got engaged even
though they only like kiss twice but
it's like they didn't even know they're
married already like yes been every day
together I watched that last five
minutes five times it is the best piece
of television I've ever seen and it's
like I was mad at them for so long for
not putting them together for eight
years but I wouldn't have felt this way
if I didn't wait for it for eight
seasons and I was so invested and
I heard a rumor that Eddie Jenko Vanessa
plane Vanessa ray is leaving the show
but I searched online and I didn't see
anything I just got some Instagram
because it can't be true I'm the show it
season HS ended now it's available on
Netflix and there abouts starts using
coming solo and it was over and people
are freaking out about the spoilers and
I went to stalk the cast Donnie Wahlberg
who's that like the main guy Jenny
McCarthy follows me on Instagram oh my
god and I went through his whole
Instagram every post on his Instagram
his video is him on a private jet he's
like so like once everyone should know
he's on a private jet but they just like
such an interesting career like New Kids
on the Block Wahlberg family while
burgers Wahlberg restaurant owner watch
repens live got married to Jenny
McCarthy now was on literally the number
one show in the world
and probably makes more money than God
that's amazing like right now he's
probably making no known that Mark
Wahlberg makes so much money but like
Mark Wahlberg like was the top dog in a
family now he it's like a little
competition for sure but Mark Wahlberg
is the top dog cuz Mark Wahlberg is so
hot totally okay this is a way that
spoilers are over I'm sorry
spoilers are over but like if you if you
don't watch a show it's incredible well
now I'll never watch it so I'm happy for
you that you got what you wanted and
that's nice that it's still on TV I know
which now I could watch Mad Men right
with everyone else but I can finish and
dinner went great what's next Candice
Swanepoel says she's quote proud of her
post-baby figure and clap back against
critics okay so can is swanepoel hit the
beach 12 days after she gave birth but
she looks amazing but I gave her a
regular person she looks amazing I guess
some like sad people were telling her
that she didn't Brooke she's so crazy
because like I would love to see what
those people look like after a baby or
even just regular right so she posted
her Instagram story the photos of her in
a bathing suit saying this is me twelve
days after having my son if you have
something bad to say about it check
yourself society can be so cruel to one
another beauty standards are sometimes
impossible for women these days I'm not
ashamed to show my postpartum tummy
I am proud actually I carried my son for
nine months in there I think I've earned
the right to have a little tummy is it
because a model well we are normal
people too so let me enjoy the beach in
peace please
I have to point out like just a little
bit of irony is like she's like beauty
standards are impossible to me she sets
the beauty standards like she's a
Victoria's Secret Angel she weighs
probably a little under a hundred pounds
I know she's really because she's
talking about 105 she sets the muni
standards and she sets unrealistic
beauty standards and so does the brand
that she works for never having a curved
model walk in their show ever so like I
totally agree like anyone who has
anything to say about a woman's body in
general especially after they just had a
baby
literally deserves a spot and how we
always say there's literally a special
place and now for boys who crawls crawl
girl is fat so anyone who has anything
to say about a woman's body in general
is an [ __ ]
especially if the woman just had a baby
but like let me not point out the irony
of like her commenting on beauty
standards when like she is the face of a
brand that literally sets unrealistic
beauty standards and it's just like
honestly so on inclusive and degrading
to women sorry all very fair but I
personally doesn't set like she doesn't
she's not doesn't work for Victoria C
sharp creative yeah and she was like
born that way just like naturally skinny
and tall sure but she looks amazing
twelve days after her I know oh my god
that's I can't even imagine what I don't
look like no totally I definitely
honestly the thought of me getting
pregnant is like the scariest thing ever
I and you know what I really do need to
get skinny before I get fat because of
the physicality no not even that because
by the way just like as a warning I
could be pregnant in the next couple
years and if we're still doing the toast
like we're doing the trust for my bed
every day why we could do it from here
no I cannot get out of bed like I just
know this you're getting a new apartment
soon just got a room with it we need to
I actually I'm wanting a second bedroom
for like studio so like I know myself
please don't be at I mean when I'm
pregnant for being completely am ia the
toast is the perfect job for a peck yes
I agree actually cuz you like I feel
like you wake up early from your body
yes from your morning sickness
yeah it's come do this and then go lay
in bed no totally but like I really feel
like I need to get in shape before I get
pregnant because like if I think it's
hard to lose right now imagine how it's
gonna be when I let her get on your ends
and then you have a baby to look after
and lose weight but it's like if you get
in shape now you're gonna put off having
a baby longer because I want to get away
and it which is like such a [ __ ] up
thing to do but you know what it's the
reality of the situation yeah and I feel
like so many celebrities like they
pretend like it doesn't bother them and
are they like high paid surrogate
because they don't want their bodies to
change and that's really crazy
that's [ __ ] up mhm whatevs are you
ready for the next story always this
actually is very exciting the job market
is poppin you guys where's this article
from this article is from CBS News very
legitimate the job market is apparently
so hot that people are ghosting
potential employers oh I never thought I
would read a headline like this all you
hear is like jobs drop stress and like
unemployment unemployment no jobs this
is so great jobs are down where are the
jobs what are the back our jobs the
much-maligned habit of ghosting has
apparently made its way into the
workplace
according to a recent LinkedIn article
people are ghosting at work and it's
driving companies crazy ghosting is when
a person abruptly goes silent or
disappears without explanation
thank you CBS News the article goes on
to explain that candidates who have
agreed to job interviews fail to show up
without any notice or further
communication and in some cases accept
jobs only to not appear for their first
day of work
that's crazy don't you sign a course ba
that's actually [ __ ] up they're just
being a dick I understand if you've got
another job and you're not gonna write
to your interview interview person sorry
I got another job because I write
they're interviewing other people to you
and a lot of times when you don't get
the job you don't hear from them you
don't ever quote the job market is so
hot right now unemployment and this is
at an 18 year low
you've got more job openings than
candidates which is the first time the
Labor Department has seen this it's a
buyers market right now LinkedIn
editor-in-chief Dan Roth told CBS this
morning on Wednesday what's a buyers
market like the buyers are in charge
like meaning the applicants are here
yeah
Suika jobs seriously the world needs us
we could get part-time jobs because
we're free around noon we are part-time
we have a part-time job here we could
attend another part-time job where you
fake work and while we're fake working
we'll do suffer the toes right it's
actually ideal though you might expect
young people are Millennials to be the
culprits Roth said ghosting is happening
at all ages that's weird it's everyone
you would think it would just be
Millennials people who are used to
dating sites yeah the truth is it's
everyone it's easier just to stop
showing up than to say no or thank you
for reaching out to me about this job
but I actually don't want it anything
right it's so awkward another reason it
might be happening according to Roth job
seekers see it as retribution for all
the times potential employers ghosted
them
very fair [ __ ] still roth warns against
it recruiters and hires are saying they
will never forget the people who up goes
to them that's true and they will take
that from job to job
oh so even if HR person goes to a
different company if you're working in
the same field in the city you'll bump
heads again it's so funny because you
really like it even not even just unlike
the job world but just like in in life
you never know who you're talking to and
you know those people like I'm sure your
friends or people that you know we're
just like inherently like not friendly
people or like just like mean and like
they think they're talking to some [ __ ]
and really that person is like you know
ahead of whatever for whatever so that's
why it really does go a long way to be
nice and I sometimes it's hard cuz
people are annoying but like I like I
can't even deal with people who are just
like naturally not friendly like even
though like I think I'm better than
everyone because I am I am like always
just like bubbly and nice to people you
know what I mean yeah honestly being
rude to people like the thought of it
just makes me uncomfortable takes more
effort it takes more effort to like diss
someone which you should only do if you
have a reason to then it does she just
be friendly and smile takes more muscles
to frown than it does to smile I mean
that's definitely not true no uh it
depends on your face I think totally and
also like I can I should get like Botox
that just keeps me like this because you
do have a good case of RBF not anymore
right not sincere not seen Botox rubber
guns are head anyways it's so exciting I
hope all of you job candidates out there
are getting what you need from the job
market that's great if someone asked if
we had part-time jobs what would you
apply for I would want to work at I
would want two things three actually I
really want to work in like a bakery ice
cream place of some sort but that's like
a lot of time on your feet like tending
to customers I could also be like one of
those people who tests like Netflix
shows like a focus group right like a
permanent focus group er or for snacks
like just giving my thoughts on snacks
and third or just being like someone I
don't know what the job title is like
someone with an office in a computer you
know like in in marketing but I don't
think they have part-time marketing you
know and they have like cubicles like I
want to be important in marketing that I
have a door that I can slam oh you can't
get that with a part-time job I know
that's tough it's my buddy or a time job
after this I don't know cuz it's
part-time so I'm not gonna say like what
my dream job would be more but I would
want to be like someone like a
consultant
like a nail polish company that needs
help naming their nail polishes and I
would be so good at that like something
created like that or if you just show up
you're good with words throughout my
ideas you don't need me from 9 to 5 of
my ideas I like I'll come in in the
afternoon and get the brief on the
project the McKenzie file hit you with
my ideas go home or another job I would
totally do and be really good at is be
like the doorman or the door person of
like a cool Club and turn people away
because for some of those people right
here you be well here's the thing
not people who just walk up and assume
like people the [ __ ] like that like
hey like know if you're nice like and be
like hey I'm just with a couple friends
like have a great time totally look I
don't care what you look like or like
how much money you want like jizeen you
look like you would add a good time to
my club you're more than welcome
I'm just the way that you ask me I feel
like doorman in this city like respond
to disrespect which is so crazy i when I
woke up to the door I'm like hi like I'm
with I'm little that person I'm like I
think I please and thank you like we're
and I get no respect some [ __ ] who is
like smelly and aggressive comes up
behind me it goes I took his torture
Libyan George who the [ __ ] is George
like my club would be literally for only
nice fun cool girls who like the toast
oh my god that would be the most fun
Club and then all the boys would want to
come right right like the method of like
letting people into clubs first well
there is no method and it's so [ __ ] up
it's so [ __ ] up how much of a bribe
would you accept in order to say there's
someone who you would not be letting in
without a bribe what would you what
would you take hundred bucks
yeah that'll do yeah I mean if they gave
me 80 I wouldn't turn it down but still
hundrets around 100 next story so I'm
just so excited at the job market I know
should apply for part-time jobs ok you
do a person let me know how it goes ok
I'm gonna check LinkedIn that would be
fun ok next up more branding news
General Mills everyone's after our Lucky
Charms they say yes a 54 year old
leprechaun is killing it in the cereal
aisle Lucky Charms with its bits of
marshmallow a mischievous pint-sized
pitchman has rung up a 20% increase in
sales over the past year making a
General Mills fastest growing cereal
brand the company said the surprising
increases made all the more shocking
because it comes as the country turns to
healthier choices at breakfast right
like who's eating marshmallows for
breakfast right and I actually have a
theory people are loving the
marshmallows said company spokesman Mike
see I mean yes that may be true but -
but - out of the box Marc
this year haven't hurt in February the
company added a unicorn shaped
marshmallow to the cereal thanks the
first new character introduced in 10
years cute also the minneapolis company
Minnesota mm-hmm introduced in 2018 a
frosted flakes version of the cereal
frosted flakes the Kara Kellogg's cereal
is in trademarks because it's descripted
that's so intricacy I have a theory okay
together the two moves created a hot
product far out distancing General Mills
overall two percent an increase in
cereal sales well you know we have the
same theory Kylie no oh they send her
like boxes of Lucky Charms that are
straight marshmallows
she always posts her insta story it
looks amazing double arrow people are
out there buying with you charms but
what I think is that like the kids who
were like eating Lucky Charms when they
were kids and like only got it every
once in a while because it's like a
sugary cereal are now grown up and have
disposable incomes and they're like I
could do whatever I want [ __ ] you mom
and they're buying their own cereal so I
think it has a lot cuz like the brands
been around for 20 plus years and like
we never had sugary cereals in our house
growing up and let alone Lucky Charms I
go eat at other kids house but now I'm a
grown woman in fact if I seen in the
grocery aisle like honeycomb honeycomb
was this [ __ ] ever got but if I was in
the grocery store and I saw it like I
wouldn't have to ask anyone like I have
my own income now like I'm in charge of
my own financial decisions so I think
that has a lot to do with it and that's
what the article is missing I don't have
any facts to prove it but I just know
that have a feeling and it seems as
though they're in tune with what's
necessary they're evolving which is
important but what's your favorite
cereal why don't we eat cereal I
actually love cereal I love a lot of
cereal
I love Reese's cereal it's so good
that's crazy that's so crazy that that's
breakfast Ursa I know no I haven't eaten
it for wreckfish since college and you
stuff like a box with Bowl and milk
what is another good sir I don't we did
myself to a bowl of cereal since middle
school I think but see I don't really
like Lucky Charms like in a bowl with
milk I just wanted us like a snack you
know just with my hand Marshman yeah
fruity pebbles and cocoa pebbles are
always a winner for sure
anything that makes your milk Rockwell's
chocolate do you like milk ooh
we're not milk people we are not a milk
family growing up like when the only two
beverages that we could drink at
breakfast we're water and our juice that
was watered down with water I just I
think milk is so disgusting
me too I drink they my coffee every day
and that's about it and I have like
calcium lines on my nails because you
know - I need to get a medic here after
this actually isn't this a nice color
someone said it really pops on the toast
oh it does also people were throwing
ideas out in the comments that we should
have a club toast and if we ever got to
the place where like the show was making
money that we could like open a club or
like a bar probably I would be so into
it I've always wanted to be a bar owner
and I have the best name for a bar but I
can't say it because someone will steal
it but also the toast lends itself to
great bar names you know it would be
like let's get toasty or something or
like just toast yeah toasted make it
hosted whatevs
okay fifth and final story which will be
a great segue into our Real Housewives
of New York recap we're honies star
LuAnn de Lesseps is dating her married
agent oh wow I didn't realize the
salaciousness of this title that he's
married I know I read this and I didn't
realize he was married till I reread it
this morning and I have good tea on the
web so you say it and then also when de
Lesseps has moved on with her married
agent page six has learned sources tell
page six at de Lesseps in Hollywood
agent rich super who were told has
recently filed for divorce from white
had been dating for a few weeks but that
things are already getting serious we
this is so funny because remember when
she was yelling at Bethany for dating a
married man who has separated but that
was a differently man
yeah I agree no but it's just like it's
funny it is it is funny super who also
wrecks comedians including Artie Lange
has been representing Delos Epps sorry
the comedians like who for several
months since she began her booming
career as a cabaret star in the countess
and friends pals of the Real Housewives
of New York star who is herself coming
off a divorce from tog done it
D'Agostino yeah technically she's
married - oh right that's true you could
switch a headline the married agent is
dating married reality TV star say that
although they've only been dating a few
weeks the couple are very close already
he's smitten with her set a palette and
she's very excited about it um like
literally who cares I had heard you know
through my secret sources last night
that LuAnn was actually fired by her
publicist yesterday according to the
publicist she's just too much to manage
and she might not be a hundred percent
sober that's just well unconfirmed to
thing I saw last week on rioni LuAnn
should have fired her publicist yeah
totally not in tune with what's
necessary bad that this has happened
even in the way that it has which brings
me to Baroni what you want to do sisters
and then I think dear honey
Verona's great madad we but I just have
thoughts it's pretty everybody doing it
yeah Roni last night was a segue episode
connecting from Luann's rehab two-parter
Kenya so there wasn't much there there
but I was thinking about her cabaret and
when it came out she had just gotten out
of rehab she was like the toast of the
town and when she started planning it it
was before rehab and it wouldn't have
been as successful if she wasn't like
this phoenix rising from the ashes so it
really goes to show like everything
happens for a reason I'm such a firm
believer in that and like when something
terrible is happening to you can't
imagine the reason why it would be
happening and then a year later you save
yourself like oh that makes so much
sense I think about all the time like
all the bad things that have happened to
me and like what came from it like I
know I wouldn't have met Ben if our dad
didn't die like I think about that all
the time because I'm we moved and that's
where I met Ben yes I think about it all
the time
every and then whatever I'm going
through something bad I think
everything's happening Servais and I'm
also like shut up that's not true but
then months later it is yeah so I
totally agree when something happens
immediately and and someone's like I
know like I know why this happened and
every shot was a reason like no no you
you know how to a year later or years
later yeah years later for sure but I
would say after a year you should have
sent but so I went to Luann's opening
night of the show which you wouldn't
have been nearly as jazzed about if she
hadn't just gotten out of rehab and
gotten and I think honestly her like
getting arrested like lifted her up to
icon status agreed and it was phenomenal
the show she really attacked the the
arrest arrested Tom debacle head-on it
was funny it was a reverent she was
great all around five stars for the show
and I thought the episode like the
preparations for the show I find
incredibly boring like her sitting with
the piano with of course Billy Billy
strict who's do you know his momma's
Elaine strict
she's like a very famous actress I can't
recall what she's from I she was either
joeys a google it she was either Joey's
agent and friends or the grandma from
the nanny I can never reach down oh no
she's docked Jack Donaghy's mom
that's why sorry I was sitting a few to
people's moms in different shows Jack
Downey's mom yes I loved her doubt and
she he really is like a very famous
Broadway producer ya know
so prestigious everything that she's
doing she's on you did it the right way
she did it the right way and everything
really happens for a reason for her and
I'm really I'm obviously very happy for
her but if she hadn't gotten arrested
and whatnot heard the show would have
been just all about Tom and that would
have been the Greta sad
yeah um then okay let's go let's go
person by person okay the only one
Bethany had Sonia over that was like
literally the cutest meal ever and
they're so cute and like I ship them so
hard they're so cute but like every time
they hang out all I can think about is
cheater brand I know and it's like they
need to hang out more for me to forget
about it by the eventually well like all
things people forget but it just makes
me feel like Bethany's really clinging
to Sonia one because Sonia's like the
most fun person and everyone loves her
right now and she's really having a
moment and if LuAnn hadn't gotten
arrested the season it would have been
so much he's in yep especially cuz last
year she like wasn't even invited to the
Berkshires yep um but I just keep
thinking like that find it really railed
on her but Sonia is so on
she is a clear-headed she is so on I
don't know what the hell happened to her
but she I don't know how to say it in
any other way than that she's on yeah
you know I mean like even like that and
I feel like now she's being who she is
like she's definitely wacky yeah and
hilarious but that's who like she wakes
up in the morning and this association
little cheering drinking her wackiness
was like turning into like slobber eNOS
when she's actually just like a funny
gal she really is offending out she's
the perfect housewife and I'm so glad
that we stuck with her for so long and
I've always loved her have and I'm so
proud of her same the best moment of
this episode was when Bethany imitated
Ramona I couldn't agree more so funny I
just got loud previews and I was like I
can't wait for this moment see it it's
so funny okay basically that guy with
the red scarf was brought there as I
guess the woman wants to set him up with
Carole but he knew Bethany and he said
he came there for her he had a feeling
she knew that they were filming and he
just went in the hopes that she would be
there all makes sense Ramona wanted him
he wanted nothing Jews Ramona Carole
thought he was hers but they didn't even
talk and then he was like obsessed with
Bethany and you could see in that
conversation and carta Hania next week
where Carole says something so [ __ ]
like she said but there's like it
doesn't matter I don't want to date him
she goes well he does want to take you
either lies so rude like sober did you
see what posted on Instagram and someone
commented like something about biting
like ask Siri like find me a better
housewife in Kerala and Syria was like
no results found so someone in Carol's
phones broken yeah
Carol someone commented why don't you
tag Bethany and Carol responded that
Bethany locked her okay so that's some
good tea I guess I mean like honestly I
couldn't be less interested in
everything going on in Tinsley's life I
agree and it just makes me so nervous
and also we know that they break up they
get back together they break up again
and now they're back together because
she's hashtagging scott Kluth in her
photos abroad and she's saying caption
just picture taken by scott just to let
Matt let us know that's it yeah a little
too thirsty for me and I like some when
they first got together and they were so
cute and depth and so different and he's
probably someone she never expected to
date like mostly a Jewish person and so
I was here for it but now I no longer am
I don't give two shits that they stay
together or not and every time she just
always is counting her chickens before
they hatch and as like a superstitious
Jewish person it makes me so nervous
like watching her move into this
apartment with a guy who are they even
together right isn't making me women
he's obviously paying for it also
knowing that like if they break up like
what is she gonna do I like girls who
are like so dependent on men and like
don't have anything like besides like
investing in their relationships like I
can't even with people like that
I can't even I just it gives me anxiety
counting your chickens before you had
you guys like it's not it's not what you
should be doing and also like her and
Carol talking in Carol's like keep it
cute like vomit no like honestly them
together I can't stand I'm like so not
on Carol's team no I'm so not on Carol's
team either and I just want to say one
thing about Ramona she looked amazing
this episode oh my god amazing and and
her Instagram she's been looking so good
dr. Sharon Giese II even though the red
scarf guy was obviously not interested
in her he had Bethany on the brain
Ramona really does have game like yeah
she was talking to him she's engaged
she's smiley she's asking questions it
went like she's so positive and I could
totally see how she gets like so many
guys I agree but that guy was also just
too young for her yeah this was like a
boring episode now that I think about it
there was so much filler like her
working out yeah because they were just
trying to squeeze in an extra episode
before carta hanging because they know
everyone's gonna watch that yeah and
actually I saw every singer in the
Hamptons over the weekend she is
actually the nicest smartest coolest
girl like ever she's like a genius she's
like has a huge job at JPMorgan
she has someone who was smart in school
and did something with it yeah good for
her and I think she's come to my party
tonight so Oh fine I'd literally invited
everyone on planet and if I know you
personally and I didn't invite you just
text me because I probably forgotten
it's not personal it's not personal who
else is around Amanda she did really do
any anything this episode they went to
Giovanni LuAnn body is amazing game
everything looked perfect on her she has
like the perfect shape she has no big
shoulders yeah but she wasn't always
like I think that were while she was
kind of like when you stop drinking
first of all guilt and now she just is
everything did her like a glove and like
I'm going to church like that was weird
like the whole episode was like fake C
scripted [ __ ]
totally but I get why they know that
will suck that they can add an extra
episode to the season and make all that
add money because they go down on a
voting Club by the way is Ramona in a
wheelchair before the boat goes down
okay cuz I was convinced but that's
scene where they're like pulling her up
on the curb is so funny so funny I'm
excited but I'm also having anxiety like
that boat scene like I don't want to
watch it I know what I'm gonna vote my
inside sources is that they literally
had no footage from that and now that I
keep watching the commercial they keep
playing the same scene where the boat
rocks up once and they see three people
like on a couch on one person's crying
what I had heard was that they were
freaking out because they had literally
no footage from that because they
literally all thought they were gonna go
down like at some point you put the
camera sound right Wow so that's just
what I heard that'll be really crazy but
honestly it's what the season needs
it's what the season and it'll shift
things into perspective like I think we
both do that something like that with
people it's like okay if I'm having a
tiff with someone that I gotta get along
with we'll put it behind us but if right
yes but it's clear now that in real life
things that got very bored I feel
nothing then it's also like if there's
someone I'm also not gonna spend time
with people that I don't want to be
around right that's true that's two fold
but that conversation where they're just
randomly talking about the guy like
they're so Bethenny used the perfect
word to describe Carole smug like she
just thinks her [ __ ] doesn't stink this
season and that she's this new woman
with a new haircut and a new life and a
new couch and without Adam and she's
single like she thinks that she is the
it girl she thinks that she's Tinsley
twenty years ago
do you know totally and tulips that Adam
sent her like they were dead they were
dad dead and sad totally
but that box that invitation was really
nice yeah it's um my friend Amanda just
sorta doing the PR for him I don't
remember
the flower company well it's beautiful
beautiful she's sending me
okay forever flowers yes is there in
water I know I thought that was weird
too okay let's do some dear toasters I
gathered by the way for those toasters
who are new we haven't done tear
toasters in a while it's asserted by
segments we try and do it once a week
preferably on Wednesdays or Thursdays
you can email dear toasters at gmail.com
and will pretty much answer anything
from dating advice relationship advice
family and buy his Bridal advice we
cover all bases boys and girls it's all
anonymous so just make sure you email to
your toasters at gmail.com so we have
content for next week but today I have
three very good ones ready mm-hmm
this one's labeled history class
bromance I'm truly in some treacherous
territory I've been taking a summer
class for the past few weeks and this
boy has caught my eye
he sits a few rows ahead of me and I
often catch myself just admiring his
beauty he is tall great style and so
handsome
after some deep stalking on social media
I found out we went to the sim similar
high schools and we both grew up in the
same area even more stalking I found out
we share similar interests like music
influencers etc how do I approach him in
a flirty way without being a creep how
do I casually say that I think we are
soul mates want to grab a coffee our
class ends in two weeks so I feel like
the talk is ticking please ladies I need
to the sage advice of human your
toasters okay first of all wait so this
is from a girl so it's a girl to a boy
which is like there's always a weird
gender dynamic I know we don't want to
admit it but like you're supposed to
wait for the boy to ask you out right
and don't use the term soulmates when
you're trying to casually like draw I
think she was joking but genuinely
jealous right I think you guys are in a
class together you should ask him if he
wants to study yes some sustenance fat
bucket of muffins right channel to go up
to a random stranger and ask him out is
definitely weird but if you have some
like study together sit next to him just
make chitchat so that it's not the first
time you're talking where your ask him
out right and like if you guys really
are soul mates then like he'll feel it
too he just might not know it yeah
because he's sitting in front of you
when you're behind him right so you need
to get the two of you alone together so
if there is chemistry he won't be able
to deny it either and then you'll go out
right and then if you just ask him out
like point-blank without ever have ever
having spoken didn't you just look like
shallow because you just like the way
that he looks right it's like if you
have a couple conversations and you feel
like there's a connection it's not that
crazy right and then like you guys
should go study and be like oh my gosh
we've studied so much we're so studious
let's get a drink and then once you have
a drink every everything bubbles up to
the top and you'll figure it out I agree
this one is [ __ ]
hilarious reading it's from a boy
anonymously I've been following you guys
since before the morning bane so when
you transition to the toast
I followed every Instagram account
Facebook page out there now because of
that I wake up with a huge pit every day
on one of the Facebook pages there was a
master post where people were sharing
their instagrams and me being thirsty
for followers of course but my Instagram
down this girl let's call her Nancy
followed me immediately and messaged me
how fabulous I look and how she wanted
to be my best friend
alright alright it was cool until it
wasn't she asked on my snapchat and then
started messaging me in an absurd amount
to the point where I wake up with
notifications from her and they all say
streak army 11 well she will also reply
to every single thing I post on snapchat
or Instagram I realized she was from the
same town across the country as my
cousin's so I asked if she if they knew
her she my cousin did know her and said
she hooked up with one of them when I
realized she was from the same town
across the country up with her as my
cousin's so I asked if she knew them her
cousin is a girl right well maybe it's
just said whatever so this girl doesn't
know the trucker hooked up with one of
the cousins ok
naturally I call my cousin ask her about
and his exact words were we kissed at a
frat party once freshman year and she
still won't leave me alone this was six
years ago so I don't know what to do of
course I thought about blocking her but
I'm nervous she'll post something in the
toaster group and I'll get roasted
because you know how the toasters are
what the heck do I do in desperate need
of help ok
and I'm sure you're great this is a guy
right yeah I'm sure you're great
fabulous guy and I can just tell you for
certain that she is trying to get in
your good graces so that you invite her
to a family function and she can get
near your cousin that's how wild girls
are even right so I wouldn't if I were
you honestly I wouldn't feel bad
blocking her because I don't think it's
about you I think it's about her
obsession with your husband where's the
thing are you answering cuz like if you
go someone for long enough they'll get
the point and stop do you mean you right
but maybe it was like lol you know you
know because you want to be rude and I
think it's more rude to block someone
than it is just to stop answering can't
you just like remove them from looking
at your stuff or something like hyenas
back and you know what if the person
does posting the toasters now we've all
seen this and there's more to the story
and I don't think the toasters will be
so ruthless right so just block her now
yeah just block her I were like unfriend
whatever you got to do I don't think
that's a big deal no one should be
waking up with a Pitt every day totally
from Nancy from Nancy who's just
trying to get close to your cousin like
she's using you brain yeah I wake up at
the pit every day for me yeah and see
from sleep over and my pit is up didn't
name her Nancy no totally that they
didn't name him Anthony what's up from
oh okay and I got a nephew that calls
Manthan E Mean Girls perfect this is our
third and final G trusters it's a long
one bear with me I am having the worst
time planning my friends Bachelorette
the bride in question let's call her
Bridget asked me in another friend to
plan her bachelorette party we agreed
him you're so excited to plan this fun
and special day for her that's when the
excitement ended
Bridget continually had to ask what was
being planned gave us suggestions as to
what we should do for example when to
call to book a party bus or when took
book the event we were going to blow a
lot I thought this was totally out of
the norm since the bride usually doesn't
know much about the day until she shows
up it's one of the UM it's the one event
she doesn't have to plan so just relax
and enjoy but boy was I wrong I spend
two weeks trying to find a party bus
that would make Bridget happy and also
within the budget of the girls who had
been invited for the day is it a luxury
bus no will I get it really get from us
from point A to point B of course I
asked if the girls invited would be
willing to pay for a luxury bus for
Bridget but the popular opinion was we
will not be on the bus long it doesn't
matter what it looks like make it cheap
so I paid the $3 deposit just to secure
the bus
Bridget then started asking so many
questions about details on the bus as
she's also trying to plan another
friend's bachelorette party which is
codeword for she actually isn't she just
wants to know details on her sleuthy
Bridget she's dated cheap buses are
dirty and that the luxury ones aren't
that expensive I said that since we are
at our event for four plus hours the bus
we have to the bus we have mass may use
that long I hate when people don't write
in English I said that we are at our
event for four plus hours the bus we
have may use that long time if you're
not being on the bus to transport a
different group oh right okay she then
begins saying that sounds sketchy and I
finally had had enough I stated that I
could attempt to get back the
non-refundable $300 and booked a
different bus the problem is what if I
don't get my deposit back what if I
booked a nicer bus and the girls back
out because it's too expensive and then
making it even more expensive for me
please help I need to get advice to get
me through this wedding hell that sounds
[ __ ] terrible I know like honestly
first of all I thought every girl does
it differently but like I thought you
plan your own bachelorette party yes see
every bachelorette party I've been on is
planned by the ride and you know
I'm noticing a pattern anytime I've
heard of a bachelorette party planned by
one of the friends it's like not all of
your friends are friends so it's like
someone on the other side of the friend
group is like this [ __ ] is planning the
party I think my friends don't want to
be with the home friends she what the
can friend is going through trying to
plan this thing I think that Brides
should plan their own bachelorette
parties unless they really really don't
want to and then take it's either all or
nothing so I think you shouldn't be like
- Bridget I love how enthusiastic you
are about this and how much like you
have you know what you want and I think
that you should do it yourself because
you're not gonna be happy with what I do
no I totally agree and the only person
who can really communicate with all
these people is the bride because
they're all connected right here they
don't know each other you can't like
your camp friend can't ask your home
friend to spend more money I don't know
you have each other's phone numbers
right so awkward that's why I mean every
about I mean I've only been on a few but
the bachelor party said I've been on had
been planned by the bride yeah and I
think I've said my thing and it's like
the bride's last hurrah like let her
plant do what everything that she wants
to do whatever bus she wants and the
friends who are really there for her
will be for her and like then let her
friends let her down not like it'll be
easier for them to be like I'm not
paying extra to your they don't know you
they're gonna say that to the bride and
she sounds like a pain in the arse
they're not right right but like if
they're just saying it to this random
girl the bride will never know what
she'll think all of our friends are
equally as good when they're not right
like you'd be an [ __ ] to the bride's
face especially if she's being an
[ __ ] to you it's like um here's the
thing about brides it's a different
thing don't ready the bride like brides
are humans too and they're worried
already they're worried already and it's
like you can hurt the bride's feelings
especially if it's just gonna get things
done faster totally like as a bride I
would have wanted to know about the
treacherous nests before so I could have
fixed it instead of showing up to a
bachelorette party I didn't walk under
on a school bus but everyone's upset
including me
also I do you think the bachelorette
party is the one event you don't plan I
thought that was a bridal shower that
like your friends and family do for you
yes that's like more like that's what I
thought I guess it's just case-by-case
and it's also like based on like your
your group like Jewish people do it all
very differently than like other
religions and other like nationalities
everyone has their own traditions this
is true and like she's planning a
bachelor party for her friend but not
for herself like I'd rather plan it for
myself and then never have to play him
on for a friend I couldn't agree more
even though ya know I'm agreement full
agreement that's tear toasters that's
your toasters you guys well you know
what I'm glad
these ones weren't so bad I'm glad
everyone's doing well out there you know
I hate when we get ones that are like oh
my god really troublesome really
troublesome and then I worry for these
people and then I feel like if I give
better advice I could have real
repercussions but if you follow this
advice and doesn't work for you like
your life will be fine right and the
bachelor party will be fine cuz once
everyone's drinking if you're a good fun
group of girls you'll make it a good
time so if you want me do kur advice
email do your toasters at gmail.com and
we'll answer it next week this has been
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show a millennial morning we're live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook so make sure you like
us on Facebook so you can catch our live
stream and then also on YouTube so make
sure you subscribe to us on YouTube to
catch our live stream on YouTube it's
live streaming is not for you you can't
make the 10:30 live show we are
available on demand in the podcast app
as audio only so make sure you subscribe
to the morning tour's podcast in the
podcast app also valve on soundcloud and
coming soon to Spotify
Barry I got a contract very exciting
because I feel like if you don't have
Android you probably have Spotify not
SoundCloud app yeah right it's really
for the Android users and I love Spotify
and to go premium and for me to be on an
artist on Spotify like that is it's a
dream I'm just a great discoverability
there's so many people on Spotify
right so I think it'll be really good
for our brand so hopefully that'll be
coming out in the next couple weeks I'm
sorry I'll shred girls no job I'm Jack
yeah sure Jackie oh problems feel free
to follow me also please subscribe to
the patreon patreon Netcom slash morning
toast if you are interested in our day
in the life video coming soon Claudia's
birthday party is gonna be lit and you
won't know because you won't see the
video if you're not a patron also we are
doing a show tomorrow just a little bit
later because like we said it tonight's
my birthday party and I don't really
have to want to have to wake up so we'll
probably be doing it around noon check
our Instagram at the morning toast for
any and all updates it has been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
this morning have an amazing Thursday
you